- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La séance est ouverte.
L'ordre du jour
appelle les questions
au gouvernement.
La parole est à monsieur
Dominique Potier
pour le groupe socialiste.
- Dominique Potier:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le Premier
ministre, aujourd'hui,
au petit matin,
une jeune femme,
une jeune agricultrice,
a perdu la vie
en s'engageant
pour ses droits,
pour ses droits de vivre,
pour ses droits
à nous nourrir.
Son mari, sa fille sont
dans un état extrêmement grave.
L'émotion est vive.
Aujourd'hui, même si
je mets de la pudeur
à le dire,
je voudrais vous dire
que je suis paysan.
Nous sommes tous
paysans aujourd'hui.
Applaudissements
Ce drame nous oblige
à la dignité,
au refus
de la démographie,
de toutes les démagogies.
Le groupe socialiste
réaffirme
trois choses très claires.
La prospérité de l'agriculture
française s'est faite
dans le cadre
de l'Union Européenne,
et c'est par l'Union
Européenne
que nous retrouverons
la prospérité
de l'agriculture française.
La deuxième
affirmation
est que nous refuserons
toujours, même
si ce n'est pas populaire,
d'opposer écologie
et économie.
Notre souveraineté
alimentaire dépend
de la santé du vivant.
Enfin, troisième
affirmation, qui,
je crois,
est partagée:
nous ne réussirons pas
à augmenter
le pouvoir d'achat
de nos concitoyens
au prix de la destruction
des emplois agricoles,
mais par le partage de la valeur.
Les normes devront
toujours être ajustées.
Elles devront toujours
être appliquées
avec humanité.
Ne nous trompons pas d'adversaire.
Aujourd'hui,
ce qui cause la souffrance
du monde paysan,
ce sont les concurrences
déloyales,
les expressions
les plus néfastes du libéralisme.
Nous formulons cinq propositions.
La première
est l'application immédiate
de la loi EGalim
et la remise en cause
de l'oligarchie
de la grande distribution.
La deuxième
est que toutes les transitions
doivent être...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je suis désolée,
vous êtes déjà au-delà
de votre temps.
Il y a cinq propositions.
Je pense que ça va beaucoup
trop déborder.
Désolée.
La parole est à monsieur
Marc Fesneau, ministre
de l'Agriculture
et de la Souveraineté alimentaire.
- Marc Fesneau:
Merci beaucoup,
madame la présidente.
Monsieur le député
Potier, merci
de votre question.
Je voudrais
m'associer aux mots
que vous avez eu pour cette jeune
agricultrice décédée
ce matin aux environs de 6h.
Elle ne faisait
que défendre son travail,
la dignité de son métier,
et partager
les difficultés et les colères
qui s'expriment aujourd'hui
autour du monde agricole.
Je voudrais dire
que je partage
les trois points
que vous avez évoqués.
Le premier,
c'est que quand il y a des drames
humains comme cela,
il ne faut céder
à aucune démagogie.
La facilité
et la démagogie,
c'est la pire des choses
en cas de crise
comme celle-là.
Le deuxième sujet
que je voulais évoquer,
c'est qu'il ne faut pas
chercher
des boucs émissaires
au niveau européen
quand ils ne sont pas là.
Nous devons
regarder comment,
dans les normes,
dans les accords internationaux,
dans les clauses
miroirs, on met
en adéquation
les nécessaires transitions.
Deuxième élément:
il faut qu'on conjugue transition
et équilibre économique.
Depuis 25 ans,
on les a mal conjugués.
Vous faites état
de la concurrence extérieure
à l'Union Européenne.
Il y a aussi
des concurrences intérieures
que nous avons créées
par des transpositions.
Il y a des
surtranspositions
qui ont mis
les agriculteurs français
en déloyauté
de concurrence par rapport
à leurs collègues européens.
Cela aussi nourrit
une colère européenne
que nous ne voulons pas non plus.
Il me semble que nous avons besoin
d'y travailler.
Il y aura d'autres questions.
Il y a notamment la question
de la répartition
de la valeur.
Nous avons posé
sur la table la question
de la loi EGalim.
Le gouvernement
a posé la question
de la répartition de la valeur.
C'est là que nous devons
être au rendez-vous.
C'est le sens
des contrôles
que nous allons exercer.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
monsieur le ministre.
Un peu de silence.
La parole est à monsieur
André Villiers
pour le groupe Horizons.
- André Villiers:
Le profond malaise
qui règne en France affecte
particulièrement
le monde agricole.
Celles
et ceux qui ont choisi,
souvent par atavisme
mais toujours
par passion,
de devenir paysans,
sont épris de liberté.
La réalité est toute autre.
Confrontés aux dures
conditions
qui leur sont réservées,
ils crient aujourd'hui
leur désarroi
à la société entière.
Les causes sont multiples
et anciennes.
Il y a l'excès
de taxes, de normes
et de bas revenus.
Le GNR, c'est l'arbre
qui cache la forêt
des exigences européennes.
Il y a une crainte
permanente de l'erreur,
dont les conséquences
financières
sont vécues avec angoisse.
C'est la corde qui tient le pendu.
La dimension
environnementale
et son cortège
de réglementations
ont demandé
aux agriculteurs de retirer
des surfaces engagées
pour limiter
à 8000 euros le montant de l'aide.
Il aura fallu
deux lois EGalim
pour tenter de partager la valeur.
La montagne a accouché
d'une souris.
La souveraineté
alimentaire
ne peut pas s'accommoder
d'un gaspillage estimé
à 20% du tonnage
des denrées produites.
Ce n'est pas acceptable.
5% des bénéficiaires de la PAC
se partagent 30%
de son enveloppe.
On ne dit pas
à nos concitoyens
qu'elle est constituée
essentiellement d'argent français.
La célèbre formule
britannique des années 80
est d'actualité:
"I want my money back".
Des centaines d'agriculteurs
se voient rayées
des bénéfices des aides de la PAC.
C'est une décision
de la profession.
Monsieur, comment
ces 6 millions
de chiffres
d'affaires peuvent
être équitables?
Venez tremper
votre paire de bottes
chez nous, dans le pays de Vauban!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
mon cher collègue.
La parole est à monsieur
le ministre
de l'Agriculture.
- Marc Fesneau:
Je n'ai nulle intention
de polémiquer.
On n'a nul intérêt d'opposer
les agricultures
entre elles.
On n'a nul intérêt
à opposer les céréaliers,
les viticulteurs
ou les éleveurs
de porcs.
Ce n'est pas rendre
service à l'agriculture
que d'opposer les agriculteurs.
La force de l'agriculture
française,
c'est sa diversité.
Nous avons des problèmes.
Nous avons essayé de résoudre
un certain nombre d'entre eux.
Nous avons redéployé
un certain nombre
de crédits qui permettront
de donner droit
à l'ensemble des demandes
qui sont faites
par les agriculteurs.
Cela avait été évoqué
par Thierry Benoit
en Bretagne.
Nous allons donner
droit aux demandes
des agriculteurs.
Les mesures
environnementales,
ce sont des mesures
qui permettent d'encourager
les pratiques vertueuses.
Nous avons besoin
de travailler
sur ces sujets.
On a collectivement
un besoin de vérité
et de lucidité.
Ca fait 25 ans que s'accumulent...
Monsieur le député,
chacun doit prendre
sa part.
Je prends la mienne.
Je prends ma part
de responsabilité,
mais le cumul des normes
sur les installations classées,
le cumul d'un certain
nombre de choses,
c'est aujourd'hui sur la table.
Je pense qu'on doit
aux agriculteurs
la vérité.
J'espère que nous travaillerons
collectivement
pour enfin résoudre
cette équation
qui est la surcharge
de normes qui pèsent
sur les agriculteurs.
Il faut des normes qui encadrent.
C'est ça que demandent
les agriculteurs.
C'est cette dignité
qu'ils réclament.
Ca fait 30 ans que ça dure!
Il va falloir trouver les moyens.
J'espère que vous serez
dans cette salle
pour voter
les mesures
dont nous avons besoin.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à madame
Mathilde Hignet
pour le groupe
La France Insoumise.
- Mathilde Hignet:
Merci, madame
la président.
Au nom du groupe
La France Insoumise,
j'adresse
nos condoléances
et notre soutien
à la famille
et aux proches
de l'agricultrice
qui a tragiquement
perdu la vie,
ainsi qu'à son mari et sa fille,
grièvement blessés
ce matin.
Applaudissements
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Agriculture,
les agriculteurs
sont des centaines
à se mobiliser
pour défendre leurs droits.
Depuis des mois,
nous vous alertons
sur le mal-être
et la grogne qui montent
dans les campagnes.
Alors que l'inflation
alimentaire
a atteint 14% en un an,
les prix payés
aux agriculteurs
ont baissé de 10%.
L'industrie
agroalimentaire a augmenté
de 71% son taux de marge.
Vous ne voyez pas le problème?
Les industriels se gavent,
tandis qu'en bout
de chaîne, les agriculteurs
et les consommateurs
se font asphyxier
avec la complicité
du gouvernement.
Il y a une absence totale
de propositions.
Il y a également
des problèmes qui relèvent
de votre responsabilité.
Lactalis méprise
ses producteurs
avec des prix honteux?
Vous laissez faire!
Les agriculteurs
bio traversent
une crise sans précédent?
Vous ne leur proposez
que des miettes!
Les aides tardent à venir
et les trésoreries
se dégradent?
Nos agriculteurs
sont en compétition
avec le reste du monde?
Vous continuez
à signer des accords
de libre-échange!
Le monde agricole
a toujours su s'adapter.
Aujourd'hui encore, il est prêt.
Il suffit de lui donner
les moyens.
Sans mesures ambitieuses,
nos campagnes risquent
de finir aussi
vides que la loi
que nous attendons depuis un an.
Réveillez-vous.
Les agriculteurs disparaissent.
Il y a un suicide
tous les deux jours.
Des centaines de familles
disparaissent
chaque année à cause
de la précarité
des marchés agricoles.
Ca suffit,
vos discours creux
et vos reculades!
Les paysans veulent vivre
de leur travail.
Allez-vous enfin leur garantir
des prix rémunérateurs
avec la mise en place
de prix plancher?
Allez-vous soutenir
notre proposition
de moratoire sur les accords
de libre-échange?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Marc Fesneau, ministre
de l'Agriculture.
- Marc Fesneau:
Dans des moments aussi graves
que ceux qu'on traverse,
je pense
que chacun doit
faire son examen
de conscience,
si je peux me permettre.
Je vais vous dire
ce que j'entends
des agriculteurs.
J'entends
des agriculteurs
qui en ont marre qu'à
longueur de plateau,
à longueur de reportage,
on vienne dénigrer
leur travail, on vienne
leur faire croire
que notre agriculture
ne serait
pas la plus vertueuse,
la plus qualitative,
la plus respectueuse
de l'environnement,
en France et à l'international.
C'est ça qui leur fait du mal.
Je prends mes responsabilités.
Je vous invite
à prendre les vôtres.
Il faut qu'on trouve
le juste prix
et la juste rémunération.
Prenez
vos responsabilités
pour leur dire
qu'on leur fait confiance
et qu'on va les
accompagner
dans les transitions,
pas
qu'on va les braquer
et leur caler
un modèle
qui n'existe
que dans des utopies.
C'est ce droit
de vérité qu'on doit
aux agriculteurs.
Allez sur le terrain.
Ecoutez les agriculteurs.
La colère qui s'exprime,
c'est une colère
de relégation, de mépris
et de déclassement.
C'est contre ça qu'il faut lutter.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
S'il vous plaît!
Merci beaucoup.
Un peu de silence,
s'il vous plaît!
Alors...
S'il vous plaît!
On va faire silence pour écouter
madame Marie Pochon
pour le groupe écologiste.
- Marie Pochon:
Je voudrais d'abord réaffirmer
toute ma solidarité aux proches
de l'agricultrice décédée
ce matin en Ariège.
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre
de l'Agriculture.
Partout dans notre pays,
la révolte gronde.
Une révolte
qui jusque-là couvait
loin de votre ministère,
plutôt habitué
à recevoir les capitaines
d'industrie.
Les agriculteurs
sont dans l'impossibilité
de vivre de leur métier.
Monsieur le ministre,
depuis 30 ans,
ceux qui nous gouvernent
ont choisi
de placer
notre modèle agricole
sur la voie
de l'industrialisation,
de la compétitivité
à outrance
et du libre-échange dérégulé...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Un peu de silence,
s'il vous plaît!
Laissez madame
Marie Pochon poser
sa question.
Si vous souhaitez
que le ministre
y répondre,
il faudrait d'abord
qu'il puisse l'entendre.
- Marie Pochon:
Des inégalités immenses
sont à déplorer,
avec 20% des fermes
qui captent plus de la moitié
des aides européennes.
100.000 fermes
ont disparu en 10 ans.
On entend qu'il faudrait
simplifier
les normes et accélérer
les procédures
au nom de la sacro-sainte
compétitivité.
Est-ce qu'on peut
être vraiment compétitifs
avec les fermes-usines
brésiliennes
qui détruisent l'Amazonie?
C'est cette agriculture
qui tue
notre capacité à produire ici.
L'agriculture n'est
rien sans écologie.
Les agriculteurs le savent.
Ils voient l'impact
des changements climatiques.
Monsieur
le ministre,
vous ne pouvez pas demander
en même temps
à nos agriculteurs
l'excellence
sans aucun moyen
tout en leur imposant
de produire à bas coût
pour être compétitifs face
au marché mondial.
Vous ne pouvez pas laisser
les prix agricoles s'effondrer
et refuser d'encadrer
les surprofits
de l'agroindustrie,
qui a vu son profit brut doubler.
Nous croyons en la protection
de l'excellence agricole française
et européenne,
celle qui garantit
des revenus,
celle qui nourrit
notre pays.
C'est celle qui nous rend fiers.
Allez-vous enfin protéger
les agriculteurs face
à ce libéralisme débridé?
Ou préférez-vous
continuer à garantir
les profits monstres
de l'agro-business?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Marc Fesneau,
ministre de l'Agriculture.
- Marc Fesneau:
Madame la présidente,
madame Marie Pochon.
Mal nommer les choses
ou mal nommer
les problèmes,
c'est ajouter aux malheurs
du monde.
Il y a un certain
nombre de sujets
sur lesquels vous avez raison.
C'est tout le sens
de l'engagement
qui a été le nôtre.
Il faut des accords
internationaux
qui respectent
des standards
et des normes
qui correspondent
aux standards
et aux normes européennes.
L'accord sur le Mercosur,
qui s'y oppose?
C'est la France.
L'accord
sur l'Australie,
qui s'y est opposé?
La France.
Il faut juger sur les actes.
Dans le commerce international,
il faut faire valoir
notre valeur,
notre excellence,
notre capacité productive.
50% de nos céréales
sont exportés
du territoire français.
Une grande partie
de notre lait,
de notre fromage,
est exportée également.
C'est pour ça
que nous avons besoin
de travailler
sur la question des normes.
Je suis d'accord
avec vous sur l'idée
qu'il faut qu'on arrive
à conjuguer l'un
et l'autre.
Mais quand vous demandez
à un éleveur d'agrandir
son bâtiment
parce qu'il faut améliorer
les conditions
de bien-être
et qu'il a 50 procédures
pour le faire, comment
vous expliquez ça?
Quand vous demandez
à un éleveur
de faire ça,
vous avez un problème.
Nous avons avancé sur le sujet.
Nous avons besoin
de réviser le statut
des normes.
Nous ne voulons pas
être aveugles
aux problèmes pour pouvoir
conjuguer l'écologie
et les questions de souveraineté.
C'est pour ça
qu'on a besoin
de bien nommer
les choses
et de bien apporter les réponses.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
Stéphane Travert
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Stéphane Travert:
Je voudrais,
au nom des députés
du groupe Renaissance,
dire notre émotion
devant le drame
qui est survenu
ce matin en Ariège.
Nos pensées
vont à la famille
et à tous les agriculteurs
de la ferme France.
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Agriculture
et de la Souveraineté
alimentaire...
Applaudissements
La France est une grande
nation agricole.
La France est reconnue
pour la qualité
et la durabilité
de son agriculture
et de ses systèmes.
Les agriculteurs font
partie de l'identité
de notre pays
et détiennent une partie
de la solution aux défis
qui nous font face.
Soyez assurés
que la représentation nationale
est fière
de ses agriculteurs,
de leur engagement
et de leur courage.
En Europe, l'Allemagne,
la Roumanie,
les Pays-Bas connaissent
des manifestations d'ampleur
sur la taxe sur les carburants.
Il y a une diminution
des cheptels, notamment.
En France,
le mouvement de colère
des agriculteurs
nous rappelle combien
le dialogue et la recherche
de solutions pérennes doivent
être au coeur de nos priorités.
A travers ces mouvements,
les producteurs veulent
nous partager un sentiment
mêlé de désespérance
et de déclassement.
Il y a celui aussi
d'être emprisonnés
dans un système fait
d'injonctions contradictoires
en France et au niveau européen.
Les agriculteurs
sont à la fois victimes
des changements
climatiques,
mais ils en sont aussi
la solution
comme acteurs majeurs
de la transition,
dont ils sont convaincus
et engagés.
Aujourd'hui,
ils nous demandent de lever
les freins
sur la compétitivité,
de respecter
les accords passés
dans le cadre de la loi EGalim.
Ils n'acceptent
plus d'être entravés
dans leur travail
quotidien
avec des contraintes
franco-françaises
qui les mettent dans l'impasse.
Ces revendications,
elles sont légitimes.
C'est le sens
du vote pour lutter
contre les surtranspositions
que j'avais déposé
et que nous avons adopté
à une très large majorité
en mai dernier.
C'est un message
de confiance
que nous devons envoyer
à l'agriculture française
car les agriculteurs
ne réclament
pas
plus d'interdictions
mais plus de solutions.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
le Premier ministre.
- Gabriel Attal:
Mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur le député
Stéphane Travert.
Tout à l'heure,
à Pamiers, dans l'Ariège,
une mère de famille,
une agricultrice,
a perdu la vie.
Son mari
et sont gravement blessés
à l'heure où nous nous parlons.
C'est une profession
qui est en deuil.
C'est notre ruralité
qui pleure
une famille.
Ce drame résonne en chacune
et chacun d'entre nous.
C'est tout un pays qui est touché.
Je veux à nouveau,
au nom du gouvernement,
rendre hommage
à cette famille
et leur dire à tous
notre soutien
et notre solidarité.
Applaudissements
Encore ce week-end,
je rencontrais
des agriculteurs dans le Rhône.
J'étais hier avec le ministre
de l'Agriculture,
avec la FNSEA et les Jeunes
agriculteurs.
J'ai rencontré l'ensemble
des organisations représentatives
des agriculteurs.
Parler
avec les agriculteurs,
c'est d'abord parler
de leur passion:
celle de leur métier,
de notre terre,
de leurs bêtes.
C'est parler
de transmission
et de leur volonté
de faire connaître
et de partager leur vocation.
C'est parler d'engagement,
d'une France
qui se lève aux aurores
chaque jour.
C'est une France
qui travaille
et qui demande
de la reconnaissance.
C'est aussi parler
d'une crainte,
celle de la disparition
de notre modèle,
de la perte de la qualité,
de l'absence
de relève.
C'est comprendre
une blessure,
celle de femmes
et d'hommes qui donnent
tout pour notre terre,
tout pour nos bêtes,
et qui se trouvent
sans cesse dénigrés,
caricaturés, acculés.
Je le dis
avec le plus grand calme,
mais aussi avec la plus grande
détermination:
parfois, vos larmes
pour nos agriculteurs ressemblent
à des larmes de crocodile.
Vraiment.
La réalité,
c'est qu'à chaque fois
que nos éleveurs familiaux
ont un projet d'extension
de leur élevage, qui s'y oppose?
Vos amis, avec votre soutien!
A chaque fois qu'un
projet est lancé
dans notre pays
sur une retenue d'eau
pour lutter
contre la sécheresse,
ce sont vos amis qui s'y opposent!
A chaque problème,
vous répondez
par une norme!
A chaque difficulté,
vous répondez
en pointant du doigt
nos agriculteurs!
Je le dis
avec le plus grand calme.
Quand certains
discours présentent
les agriculteurs
comme des tortionnaires
de leurs animaux,
comme des bandits,
on aimerait aussi entendre
vos indignations
et votre défense
du modèle agricole.
Parler
avec nos agriculteurs,
c'est évidemment parler
avec des femmes,
des hommes,
qui sont évidemment
dans l'angoisse.
Je vais y revenir.
C'est parler
avec des femmes
et des hommes lucides.
Ils sont lucides
sur l'importance
de l'Union Européenne.
Ca a été redit
par le ministre Marc Fesneau.
Il y a une lucidité
face
à ceux qui butinent
de colère en colère,
en donnant le sentiment
qu'on pourrait sortir
de l'Union Européenne.
Notre président
est aujourd'hui
avec les pêcheurs.
On y reviendra tout à l'heure.
Aujourd'hui,
on en parle beaucoup,
il y a des caméras.
Le 26 décembre,
quand les pêcheurs
en colère criaient
leurs revendications,
on n'a pas vu monsieur
Jordan Bardella,
mais madame Métayer,
une députée
de cette majorité,
qui, elle,
n'était pas
en vacances,
mais sur le terrain avec eux.
En échangeant
avec les représentants
de nos agriculteurs,
nous avons eu l'occasion
de revenir sur les grands sujets.
Vous l'avez fait,
monsieur Stéphane Travert.
Il y a des enjeux
de très court terme
sur le versement
des aides
qui sont dues
à nos agriculteurs
après les catastrophes
qui sont survenues
et face aux maladies.
Il y a l'enjeu
des négociations commerciales.
Nous aurons l'occasion,
d'ici la fin
de semaine, d'annoncer
des initiatives
en la matière.
La loi EGalim doit être respectée.
On ne renégocie pas les matières
premières agricoles.
Nous avancerons également
sur la question
des normes de la simplification.
Nous avons engagé
un travail
avec la représentation
des agriculteurs.
Nous regarderons
toutes les propositions
et nous prendrons
toutes les mesures utiles
et nécessaires
dans le cadre du projet
de loi porté par le ministre
de l'Agriculture.
Nous allons avancer
sans tabou,
sans faux-semblants,
avec une détermination
et la mobilisation
de cette majorité,
qui n'a jamais fait défaut
à nos agriculteurs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole
est à monsieur Grégoire
de Fournas,
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Grégoire de Fournas:
Ma question s'adresse
au Premier ministre.
Je voudrais commencer
par rendre hommage
à cette agricultrice
tuée ce matin
par un chauffard lors d'une
manifestation d'agriculteurs
dans l'Ariège.
Applaudissements
- C'est lamentable!
- Grégoire de Fournas:
Depuis plusieurs semaines,
les agriculteurs
manifestent leur ras-le-bol
de votre politique
totalement incohérente
qui consiste
à leur imposer toujours
plus de normes
tout en les mettant
en concurrence
avec la terre entière.
Nous alertons des mois
sur cette France rurale
et du travail qui n'en peut plus.
Malgré nos mises
en garde,
vous avez voté le traité
de libre-échange
avec la Nouvelle-Zélande,
qui va faire venir
des milliers
de tonnes de viande
et de lait,
dont la production ne respecte
aucune des normes imposées
à nos agriculteurs.
Vous soutenez Farm to Fork,
cette stratégie européenne
de décroissance
agricole dictée
par les pires écologistes
d'extrême gauche.
Au mois
de décembre,
et malgré notre ferme
opposition,
vous avez fait voter
une augmentation
de la fiscalité
sur le GNR,
alors que l'agriculture
française
est déjà asphyxiée
par les charges.
Nos agriculteurs sont à l'agonie.
Vous essayez
de gagner du temps
par vos concertations
stériles
et la promesse d'une loi
d'orientation agricole
dont la vacuité
ne réglera
aucun des problèmes
des agriculteurs.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre, cessez
votre enfumage
et répondez
à ces trois questions
essentielles.
Allez-vous revenir
sur l'augmentation
de la fiscalité sur le GNR?
Allez-vous dénoncer le traité
de libre-échange
avec la Nouvelle-Zélande
et abandonner
les négociations avec le Mercosur?
Allez-vous mettre fin
à l'écologie punitive
et à la stratégie
Farm to Fork
que vous avez votée
au Parlement européen
avec les écologistes?
Répondez à ces trois questions.
Tout le reste n'est que bavardage.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur
Marc Fesneau, ministre
de l'Agriculture.
- Marc Fesneau:
Monsieur le député Grégoire
de Fournas, on n'est
jamais surpris
avec vous, vous n'êtes jamais
en retard d'une démagogie
et d'une récupération.
Oui, nous avons des problèmes.
Oui, nous avons besoin
qu'au travers
des normes, au travers
de la simplification,
au travers de la compétitivité...
Nous travaillons
pour les agriculteurs.
Vous êtes un élu
qui connaît son territoire.
Vous êtes un élu de Gironde.
Les agriculteurs
de Gironde ont besoin
de compétitivité.
Ils ont besoin
qu'on les accompagne.
Nous l'avons fait en 2023
avec un versement
de 200 millions d'euros.
Si le Bordeaux
ne s'exporte pas,
vous m'expliquerez
comment il pourra
y avoir une viticulture
en Gironde.
Ils ont besoin
d'être accompagnés
dans la compétitivité.
Ils n'ont pas besoin
d'être enfermés
dans une autarcie
qui les condamne.
On a besoin
de travailler là-dessus.
Je veux répondre
sur la question
du GNR.
Vous avez mis
en place avec Bruno
Le Maire un mécanisme
qui est un mécanisme
de baisse
des avantages fiscaux
avec des compensations
fiscales
qui permettent de compenser
à l'euro près.
Il s'avère,
et c'est ce que disent
les manifestants,
que sur les territoires,
ça ne se répartit pas forcément
de façon homogène.
Je l'ai dit.
On est en train
de travailler
et de regarder
avec les organisations
professionnelles comment
les choses peuvent s'équilibrer
et comment on peut
avoir une trajectoire
sur la fiscalité
et une trajectoire
qui soit bien répartie
sur l'ensemble
des territoires
et qui corresponde
à l'ensemble des besoins
des agriculteurs.
Il faut leur dire la vérité.
Il faut répondre
à leurs problèmes.
Je prends ma part des choses.
Chacun doit prendre
sa part des choses
qui n'ont pas été faites.
Il me semble qu'il faut accélérer.
Si vous pouviez sortir
de la démagogie,
peut-être
que nous pourrions avancer
pour l'agriculture.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le député?
- Grégoire
de Fournas:
Vous n'êtes pas
agriculteur,
je suis viticulteur.
Mon père, qui est aussi
viticulteur,
a 62 ans
et ne se paye
plus depuis plus d'un an.
Arrêtez avec vos accusations!
L'agriculture
française est au bord
du gouffre!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Julien Dive
pour le groupe
Les Républicains.
- Julien Dive:
Les Républicains s'associent
à la douleur à l'égard
de la famille d'Alexandra.
Leur fin sera notre fin.
La colère des agriculteurs
qui éclate
dans tout le pays
frôle le point
de non-retour.
C'est la conséquence
des promesses tombées
au champ d'honneur
qui ont fini
de les exaspérer.
Votre majorité
leur promet des lois
pendant qu'au
Parlement européen,
on vote la décroissance.
Quelle imposture!
Vous participez au déclin
de l'agriculture française.
Ce n'est pas un projet
de loi
que vous retardez,
mais l'avenir même
de notre agriculture.
Juillet, automne,
décembre, janvier...
Il y a encore
quelques jours,
vous étiez prêt
à présenter au Conseil
des ministres un texte
pour tenter d'acheter
la paix sociale agricole.
Vous nous menez en bateau.
Les contraintes sont toujours
plus pressantes.
Les contrôles sont toujours
plus inquisiteurs
alors qu'à côté,
nous accueillons
des produits étrangers
selon des règles
que nous ne tolérons pas
chez nous.
Ne soyons pas
plus royalistes
que le roi sur les produits
agricoles.
Les agriculteurs
vous réclament
des prix, vous bricolez
une pseudo-loi
sur les négociations
commerciales,
sans effet.
L'Assemblée nationale
vote à l'unanimité
la réforme du système
de retraite agricole.
Réveillez-vous!
Les agriculteurs
n'ont pas à choisir
entre les zadistes
qui les zigouillent
et les opportunistes
comme Jordan Bardella
qui découvrent les fermes.
Il faut leur permettre
de vivre,
leur permettre
d'être bien rémunérés.
Il faut une abrogation
des surtranspositions abusives
et une maîtrise
des charges sociales,
un investissement
pour le stockage
de l'eau.
Quelles sont vos solutions
aujourd'hui
et maintenant?
Ils méritent
des réponses et non
des reports sans fin.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur
Marc Fesneau, ministre
de l'Agriculture.
- Marc Fesneau:
Monsieur le député Julien Dive,
vous connaissez bien ces sujets.
Je vais essayer
de vous répondre
sur un certain nombre de points.
Je ne connais pas
un agriculteur
ou une organisation
professionnelle
qui voudrait qu'on revienne
sur la loi EGalim.
Ils nous demandent
d'aller plus loin.
Cette loi
a été
un premier pas
sur la rémunération.
On a parlé de négociations
commerciales.
Ca fait partie de la loi EGalim.
On a besoin
de faire en sorte
que la contractualisation
soit respectée.
On doit faire en sorte
qu'un certain nombre
de filières entrent
dans la loi EGalim.
Sur la loi
d'orientation,
nous avions un texte
centré sur la question
du renouvellement des générations.
Il y a eu des moyens
importants
qui ont été votés.
Dans le moment
qu'on traverse,
on a besoin d'accélérer
sur un certain nombre
de nos procédures,
qui étaient incluses
dans le pacte.
C'est pour ça qu'il faut
prendre
ce temps pour répondre
concrètement
aux demandes qui sont celles
des agriculteurs.
Nous avons un sujet européen.
C'est moi qui ai pris
l'initiative d'une demande
de suppression
de l'obligation des 4%
de jachère.
Dans ce monde
où nous importons 40 millions
de tonnes de céréales,
il faut
qu'on arrête
de mettre en jachère
un certain nombre de terres
qui pourraient produire.
On attend de la Commission
qu'elle réponde.
C'est le combat
que nous continuons
à mener.
C'est la France qui a mené
des négociations
pour faire en sorte
que le texte
sur la restauration
de la nature
n'aboutisse pas à la mise
sous cloche
de la nature.
Oui, il y a de la bataille
à mener.
Oui, il faut
faire en sorte
que dans le Green Deal,
on vienne conjuguer
les transitions.
Il y a besoin de transition.
Il y a des secteurs entiers
de l'agriculture
qui sont en grande
difficulté
du fait du dérèglement climatique.
On a besoin
de le conjuguer
avec la souveraineté.
C'est ce combat
qu'il faut continuer
à mener, y compris
au niveau européen.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Mathieu Lefèvre
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Mathieu Lefèvre:
Ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre
de l'Economie,
des Finances
et de la Souveraineté
industrielle et numérique.
Depuis 2017,
sous l'autorité du président
de la République,
vous incarnez
une politique économique
qui libère l'activité
et protège les Français
des crises
que nous avons connues.
Face à la crise
sanitaire,
vous étiez là.
Face à la crise
énergétique,
vous étiez là.
Grâce au bouclier
énergétique, l'Etat
a pris en charge
la moitié de la facture
des Français.
Grâce à cette politique
qu'a soutenue
la majorité,
la facture d'électricité
des Français
est parmi les plus basses
d'Europe.
Aujourd'hui,
les oppositions s'indignent
de la sortie
des dispositifs de crise.
Certains par pure
hypocrisie et d'autres
par paresse intellectuelle.
A l'extrême droite,
on déplore les causes
et les conséquences
des causes
qu'on chérit.
L'extrême droite a soutenu
l'agresseur russe
en Ukraine,
grand responsable
de la hausse des prix
de l'électricité.
A l'extrême gauche,
on voudrait se priver
des recettes
qui permettent de financer
le chèque énergie
pour les plus modestes
et qui permettent
le développement
des énergies renouvelables.
Extrême gauche et extrême
droite joignent
leurs voix
pour implorer le retour
du bouclier énergétique
contre lequel
ils ont voté.
Mes chers
collègues,
si nous avions attendu
ces oppositions,
les factures
des Français auraient
plus que doublé
ces trois dernières années.
Les Français doivent le savoir.
Autour de Gabriel Attal,
nous formons
une majorité responsable.
Une majorité qui refuse
le déclassement,
qui refuse l'endettement,
une majorité
qui sait que la dette
d'aujourd'hui,
ce sont les impôts de demain.
Pour l'ensemble
de ces raisons,
nous soutenons que la sortie
de crise signifie sortir
des dispositifs de crise.
Comment le gouvernement
entend-il oeuvrer
pour faire en sorte
que les prix
de l'électricité
soient plus bas
en France qu'ailleurs?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur
Bruno Le Maire,
ministre chargé
de l'Economie, des Finances
et de la Souveraineté
industrielle
et numérique.
- Bruno Le Maire:
Monsieur le député Lefèvre...
Quand les prix
de l'électricité
ont explosé, monsieur le député
Mathieu Lefèvre,
cette majorité a mis en place
un bouclier tarifaire
sur l'électricité
qui nous a permis
de prendre en charge la moitié
des factures d'électricité
de nos compatriotes.
Ce bouclier,
vous avez voté contre.
Vous avez voté contre également.
Vous n'avez aucune leçon
de pouvoir d'achat
à nous donner
pour la protection
de nos compatriotes.
Nous avons toujours
indiqué,
avec le Premier ministre
et le président
de la République,
que nous sortirions
progressivement
de ce bouclier tarifaire.
Il y avait une taxe
intérieure
sur la consommation finale
de l'électricité.
Elle était à 32 euros
le mégawattheure
avant la crise.
Nous l'avons
ramenée à 1 euro
pendant la crise.
Nous la faisons
progressivement remonter
à 21 euros,
en dessous
de ce qu'elle
était avant la crise,
pour sortir
progressivement
et pour continuer à financer
le chèque énergie
des plus modestes,
c'est-à-dire
les 6 millions de ménages
qui vont toucher
cette somme pour éviter
la précarité énergétique.
Nous faisons en sorte
que nos compatriotes
de Corse
et d'Outre-mer
ne payent pas
leur électricité
plus cher.
C'est à la fois juste
et responsable.
Ca définit bien notre majorité.
Si nous voulons,
la prochaine fois,
protéger
nos compatriotes aussi
bien que nous l'avons
fait
pendant la crise du Covid,
il faut savoir sortir
définitivement du quoi
qu'il en coûte.
C'est aussi
une question de justice
et une question de responsabilité.
C'est le sens
de la décision
que nous avons prise
sur les tarifs
de l'électricité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Sébastien Jumel
pour le groupe GDR.
- Sébastien Jumel:
Je le dis avec gravité:
ils veulent nourrir, pas mourir.
Avec gravité, au moment
où un dramatique accident
de la route a endeuillé
une famille d'agriculteurs
en Ariège.
Le groupe GDR
s'associe à l'hommage
à cette famille
qui manifestait simplement
pour sa dignité.
Ils veulent nourrir, pas mourir.
Ils sont asphyxiés par des choix
politiques libéraux,
technocrates,
qui tournent le dos
à la terre et à la mer
nourricières.
Au sortir du confinement,
le président promettait
de revenir aux fondamentaux,
à la souveraineté alimentaire
du pays, mais le fossé n'a
jamais été aussi grand
entre les promesses
de l'exécutif
et la réalité
quotidienne des artisans
de notre souveraineté alimentaire.
Pêcheurs et agriculteurs
sont lestés
de boulets.
Notre agriculture
et notre élevage vivent
des crises majeures.
Tout le démontre:
barrages sur les routes,
fermetures de laiteries
en Normandie, indignité
des négociations
commerciales qui réservent
aux producteurs le sort
des citrons pressés,
accords de libre-échange
qui fondent
sur notre agriculture
comme le loup
sur l'agneau.
A la pêche, même tempête:
450 bateaux assignés
à quai autour du golfe
de Gascogne, Brexit,
envolée des prix
du gasoil
avec des aides taries
pour les armements
à plusieurs navires,
avalanche de contraintes
réglementaires et,
pour couronner
le tout, baisse des quotas.
En Normandie, Bretagne
et Hauts-de-France,
la filière est menacée
alors qu'il n'y
a pas de ministre en exercice!
Vous supprimez la détaxe
sur le gasoil agricole,
vous laissez
filer les quotas
de notre pêche artisanale,
vous ajoutez 10% d'électricité
pour tout le monde.
Monsieur Marc Fesneau,
pas de pipeau,
pas de bla-bla, pas de posture.
Les réponses,
vous les devez
à ceux qui nourrissent
les Français.
Vous leur devez des actes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur
Marc Fesneau, ministre
de l'Agriculture.
- Marc Fesneau:
Monsieur le député Jumel,
vous venez à la fois
d'une terre agricole
et d'une terre de pêcheurs.
Je ne vais pas vous faire
de bla-bla.
J'ai parlé tout à l'heure
des lois EGalim.
Elles ont permis
de reposer la question
de la juste rémunération.
Je suis sûr que nous pourrons
partager ensemble
la nécessité
que nous battions en brèche
tous ceux qui viennent
nous expliquer
que le juste prix,
c'est le prix
le plus bas.
L'agriculture a un coût.
Elle doit trouver son prix.
C'est notre responsabilité
de faire appliquer
les lois
qui ont été votées
dans les assemblées.
C'est notre responsabilité
collectivement
de faire en sorte
que dans le débat,
on vienne
à chaque fois dire:
"Quelle est la rémunération
des agriculteurs
et des pêcheurs?"
Les agriculteurs ont besoin
d'être accompagnés
dans les transitions.
Le budget de l'agriculture
cette année,
c'est 1,2 milliard
d'euros de plus.
Pour répondre à la question
de monsieur Julien Dive,
c'est 250 millions
pour trouver
des alternatives aux produits
phytosanitaires.
Ca va permettre
aux agriculteurs d'anticiper
les éléments de transition.
Troisième élément:
les négociations.
Nous allons discuter
avec les filières laitières,
comme je l'ai
fait
depuis que je suis arrivé
dans mon ministère,
pour faire en sorte
que tout le monde prenne
ses responsabilités
dans le temps
qu'il reste dans les négociations.
C'est ce que nous avons fait
l'an dernier.
Je voudrais
vous dire un mot
sur les accords internationaux.
Vous êtes une terre laitière,
qui donc exporte
des produits laitiers.
On a besoin de renforcer
la compétitivité
de cette filière,
de favoriser l'installation
et d'alléger un certain
nombre de normes.
Vous nous disiez
que les agriculteurs voulaient
nourrir et pas mourir.
Vous avez raison.
Ils veulent des prix
rémunérateurs
et pas la course
à l'échalote
entre la grande
distribution et le prix
le plus bas.
Ce sont des éléments
que le Premier ministre présentera
dans les jours qui viennent
pour avancer concrètement
sur ce sujet.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame
Martine Froger
pour le groupe LIOT.
- Martine Froger:
Ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre
de l'Agriculture.
Je m'adresse
à vous en tant que députée
de l'Ariège,
une Ariège meurtrie
en ce jour sombre.
Ce matin, à Pamiers, Alexandra,
jeune agricultrice
de 35 ans,
a été fauchée
alors qu'elle manifestait
pacifiquement
avec sa famille
et les agriculteurs ariégeois.
Ils étaient présents
sur ce barrage
pour exprimer leur colère
et leur incompréhension
contre un système
qui abandonne
nos paysans.
Son mari et sa fille
sont très grièvement blessés.
Toutes mes pensées vont à eux.
J'adresse
toutes mes condoléances
à la famille, aux proches
et à l'ensemble
du monde paysan
qui est endeuillé aujourd'hui.
J'associe mon collègue
député de l'Ariège,
Laurent Panifous,
qui est actuellement
en place aux côtés
des agriculteurs.
Cette terrible nouvelle
nous bouleverse.
Nous avons à y répondre.
Depuis plusieurs
mois, la colère
des agriculteurs
éclate au grand jour.
Ce n'est pas une colère
épisodique,
mais le résultat de conditions
de vie inacceptables.
Les agriculteurs
se sentent abandonnés,
stigmatisés,
caricaturés, mal-aimés.
Leur colère est multifactorielle.
Augmentation
des matières premières
et de l'énergie
verte, augmentation
de la taxe sur le GNR,
des tâches administratives
toujours plus contraignantes.
Les retards
de versement de la PAC
sont devenus la règle en Ariège.
Les versements
n'interviennent toujours pas.
Malgré les promesses,
les lois EGalim 1
et 2
ne sont toujours pas appliquées.
Enfin faut-il rappeler
que certains travaillent jusqu'à
80 heures par semaine
sans disposer
pour autant de revenus décents.
Qui d'autre accepterait
de travailler
dans ces conditions?
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Agriculture,
je vous le demande
solennellement,
combien d'autres
drames, suicides
ou accidents,
faudra-t-il pour qu'enfin,
nos agricultures soient entendues?
Monsieur le ministre,
prenez la mesure
du désarroi,
du découragement
et de la colère du monde agricole.
Venez les rencontrer.
Venez en Occitanie.
Il n'est plus temps d'attendre.
L'agriculture doit être déclarée
priorité nationale.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Marc Fesneau,
ministre de l'Agriculture.
- Marc Fesneau:
Madame la députée Martine Froger,
je voudrais
vous remercier
de votre question
et de la dignité
de votre question.
Les problèmes
que vous posez,
le drame que vous avez vécu
dans l'Ariège,
sont réels.
Je voudrais
m'incliner en mémoire
de cette jeune agricultrice.
Elle défendait
son métier pacifiquement
à un endroit
où il s'était organisé
un rassemblement.
La justice dira
ce qu'il en est de cet accident.
Je voudrais
m'associer à la peine
de sa famille et à la peine
des agriculteurs
de l'Ariège
et à la peine
de toute la nation face
à ce drame inconcevable
quand on veut défendre ce métier.
Deuxième élément de réponse:
je me rendrai,
dans les minutes
qui viennent, en Ariège
pour témoigner
du soutien de la nation
et du gouvernement
dans ce territoire endeuillé,
qui connaît de nombreuses
difficultés.
Je me souviens
d'un déplacement
que j'avais fait à vos côtés.
Nous avions évoqué le sujet
de la prédation,
qui nourrit beaucoup
d'incompréhension
dans le monde
agricole, sur lequel
il faudra avancer, celui du loup.
Nous serons à vos côtés
sur ces sujets.
Ils ont besoin
de reconnaissance,
ils ont besoin
que dans ces territoires,
on puisse reconnaître
les spécificités
et les handicaps particuliers
qui concernent l'accès
à l'eau, notamment.
Ils ont besoin
d'être accompagnés
dans les transitions.
C'est le sens des fonds
de transition
que nous mettons sur la table.
Je me rendrai en Ariège et,
prochainement,
en Occitanie.
C'est une région
qui est particulièrement
en souffrance.
Je vais m'y rendre.
Le travail que nous ferons
les semaines suivantes,
nous le ferons
en n'oubliant pas
cette jeune femme.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à présent à madame
Anne-Laure Babault
pour le groupe démocrate.
- Anne-Laure Babault:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Comme nos collègues,
le groupe démocrate
a une pensée émue pour la jeune
agricultrice décédée
ce matin
ainsi que pour son mari
et sa fille
qui sont dans un état grave.
Toutes nos pensées
vont à leurs proches.
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre
de l'Economie.
Elle concerne la question
des négociations commerciales
qui impactent directement
nos agriculteurs.
Comme vous le savez,
il nous reste
sept jours pour aboutir
aux négociations commerciales
entre les distributeurs
et les industriels.
C'est donc
le moment d'agir,
d'être auprès
de nos entreprises,
de nos agriculteurs
et de contrôler massivement
nos distributeurs et certains
industriels qui,
régulièrement,
ne respectent pas
la loi.
Nos agriculteurs sonnent l'alarme.
Ils sont les victimes
d'un modèle économique
qui les dessert.
Ils sont les victimes
de la course
au prix le plus bas,
d'un partage
de la valeur
qui n'est pas équitable.
1 agriculteurs sur 5
vit sous le seuil
de pauvreté.
5 euro de l'heure,
c'est ce que gagne
en moyenne un agriculteur
exploitant.
Si nous voulons
manger français,
la question du revenu
agricole et central.
Si la transition
agroécologique doit
se mener activement,
elle a un coût.
Les agriculteurs
ne doivent
plus être la variable
d'ajustement.
La loi EGalim a pour objectif
de sanctuariser
les matières premières agricoles.
Ces dernières années,
nous avons pu constater
des améliorations
dans les échanges,
mais cette année,
dans les négociations,
ce n'est pas le cas.
En novembre dernier,
vous aviez annoncé
une mission
gouvernementale afin
de travailler
en profondeur le sujet.
Dans l'immédiat,
je voudrais savoir
quelles actions
vous comptez mettre
en place pour répondre
à la souffrance
de nos agriculteurs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Madame la députée, la
loi EGalim,
toute la loi, doit
être intégralement
et rigoureusement respectée.
Nous y veillerons
avec le ministre
de l'Agriculture
et avec le Premier ministre.
Nous veillerons au respect
de la loi EGalim
sur le volet aval de la loi
qui prévoit qu'entre
les producteurs et les industriels
transformateurs,
un certain nombre
de clauses doivent figurer
dans les contrats.
J'y suis d'autant
plus attaché
que j'ai mis en place
ces contrats
pour protéger le revenu
des producteurs agricoles.
Il y a une clause
de révision des prix,
ça doit être le cas
dans chaque contrat.
Il doit y avoir une clause
de transparence
dans chaque contrat.
Enfin, un prix est un prix.
Quand un industriel
s'est engagé auprès
d'un producteur de lait rémunéré
à un certain prix,
celui-ci doit
être rigoureusement respecté.
Nous doublerons
les contrôles
sur les transformateurs
industriels.
Nous voulons assurer
le bon contrôle
du respect des
contrats entre industriels
transformateurs
et producteurs.
En aval, même chose.
Nous avons des dispositions
voulues
par les députés
et une clause de soclage.
Elle prévoit que, lorsqu'il
y a une variation
du prix du produit
dans la grande distribution,
le revenu
des agriculteurs
ne doit pas être la variable
d'ajustement.
Nous veillerons
à ce que cette clause
soit rigoureusement respectée.
Nous multiplierons
les contrôles nécessaires
et nous prononcerons
toutes les sanctions
exemplaires
pour faire respecter
la loi EGalim
par les distributeurs
comme par les industriels
pour protéger les revenus
des producteurs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, monsieur
le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
Kévin Pfeffer.
- Kévin Pfeffer:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Economie,
ça y est, vous avez eu
la lourde charge d'annoncer
la première grande mesure
du gouvernement de Gabriel Attal,
vous qui promettiez
qu'il n'y
aurait pas de rattrapage des prix.
Pourtant, une hausse
de 10% sera
bien appliquée en février 2024
sur l'électricité.
La 4e hausse
sur les prix
de l'électricité
depuis Emmanuel Macron.
En moyenne, ce sera
18 euros par mois
en plus
pour une famille qui se chauffe
à l'électricité.
+116 euros par mois
pour nos boulangers.
Combien de milliers
d'euros ajoutés
à la détresse de nos agriculteurs?
Les Français sont condamnés
à rembourser l'argent
que vous avez distribué
pendant les élections.
Vous devriez avoir honte
de ces résultats
après sept ans au pouvoir.
Malgré toutes vos excuses
et tous
vos mensonges, ces hausses
sont bien le fruit des choix
énergétiques erratiques
de votre gouvernement
et de votre choix
de rétablir une taxe
alors que le prix
de
l'électricité baisse
sur les marchés.
Le RN réitère
ses propositions:
baisse de la TVA
sur toutes les énergies,
libérer la France
du marché européen
sur l'électricité
et investir massivement
sur l'énergie nucléaire.
Monsieur le ministre,
la première décision
du gouvernement
a été d'affaiblir
le pouvoir d'achat des Français.
Combien de temps
allez-vous faire exploser
les factures des Français?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
la parole
est à monsieur Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur
le député,
vous êtes un peu pingre
avec les Français.
Votre proposition
de baisse de la TVA
à 5,5%
sur l'électricité
des Français, ça représente
une petite économie
pour les ménages
là où nous avons pris
en charge la moitié
de la facture
jusqu'à 1000 euros
pour les ménages par an.
Nous avons fait trois fois mieux,
nous sommes trois fois
plus généreux
que vous pour défendre
le pouvoir d'achat
des Français.
Vous nous parlez de nucléaire,
de population précaire,
d'énergies renouvelables, mais
qui
va financer les énergies
renouvelables
sinon la taxe intérieure
sur la consommation finale
de l'électricité?
Elle est là
pour financer l'avenir
de l'électricité française,
sa souveraineté
et son indépendance
en matière de production
électrique.
Je pensais
que le Rassemblement National
était attaché
à l'indépendance
et à la souveraineté
française,
ce n'est pas le cas.
Cet exemple
de la taxe intérieure
sur la consommation finale
de l'électricité,
elle montre assez bien
l'irresponsabilité totale
du Rassemblement National
et elle montre assez
bien
ce que vous êtes comme formation
politique.
Vous n'avez
aucune solution
pour le passé,
vous n'avez que des critiques
pour le présent
et vous n'avez
aucune proposition
pour l'avenir,
voilà qui résume
bien le Rassemblement National!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, monsieur
le ministre.
Monsieur le député?
- Kévin Pfeffer: Ce
qui est bien,
c'est que c'est toujours
la faute
des autres, jamais la vôtre.
Qui a abandonné nos centrales
nucléaires?
C'est vous!
Qui nous a rendu
dépendants du gaz russe?
C'est vous!
Vous avez fait les mauvais choix.
Demain, nous ferons les bons!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le ministre?
- Bruno Le Maire:
Qui a dit que l'énergie nucléaire
était extrêmement
dangereuse
et qu'il fallait en sortir?
Marine Le Pen, la présidente
du Rassemblement National!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur David Habib.
- David Habib: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Je veux aussi dire
ma grande émotion
après ce qui s'est passé ce matin.
Je ne vais pas évoquer
les questions agricoles,
mais je vais
évoquer un dossier
qui pourrait relever
de ce que les agriculteurs
ont expliqué:
"On marche sur la tête."
Il y a un projet bien
avancé d'injection
de CO2 dans un bassin.
Ce sont des projets portés
par diverses industriels français.
Toutes les organisations,
tous les industriels,
tous les élus,
tous les députés
et tous les habitants sont contre.
Je veux ici saluer l'écoute
et la disponibilité
de Roland Lescure.
Aujourd'hui,
c'est à l'Etat de dire
ce qu'il veut.
Il n'est pas possible
d'injecter
et d'extraire
concomitamment
dans une même cavité.
En géologie,
le "en même temps",
ça n'existe pas.
Depuis 2010, à l'initiative
des industriels,
des syndicats
et des collectivités locales,
la commune concernée
a changé son logiciel.
Nous avons ainsi réussi
la réindustrialisation
de notre bassin industriel.
De par la très forte
teneur en soufre
de notre gaz,
nous avons obtenu
une dérogation à la loi Hulot.
Le projet Picasso mettrait
un terme à cette activité.
C'est 80 emplois.
La biochimie, c'est 1500 emplois.
L'injection
n'est pas rejetée en soi,
mais cette commune
ne saurait être sacrifiée
pour des groupes qui redoutent
la taxe européenne
de 2026.
Au-delà des aspects
environnementaux
et d'images,
nous souhaitons connaître
la position de l'Etat
sur cette question.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le député,
vous connaissez
notre ambition,
nous voulons faire de la France
la première nation décarbonée
en Europe à horizon 2040.
Nous voulons étudier
toutes les solutions,
y compris
le stockage géologique de CO2.
Nous sommes ouverts
à cette possibilité.
Sur ce site, c'est à peu près
50 millions de tonnes
qui pourraient
être stockées.
Nous pouvons aussi
produire du ciment.
Si nous voulons
décarboner, il n'y
a pas d'autres solutions
pour le moment
que de stocker le carbone.
Nous sommes ouverts
à cette option.
Nous n'avons pas été saisis d'une
demande formelle
sur le projet Picasso.
La décision de l'Etat
sera rendue
en fonction de trois critères.
D'abord, l'acceptabilité
de la population.
Je le dis comme ministre
en charge désormais
de l'énergie,
il faut que,
sur tous les projets
énergétiques,
la population soit convaincue.
Deuxième condition: le respect
de nos critères environnementaux.
Troisième condition:
la défense de l'emploi industriel.
En créant du stockage
géologique
de CO2,
il ne faut pas détruire
d'autres emplois sur le site.
Nous sommes alors ouverts
à ces propositions.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Paul Vannier.
- Paul Vannier: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
la ministre
de l'Ecole privée
étant en situation
de conflit d'intérêts,
je vous adresse ma question.
Lundi dernier, le journal
Mediapart révélait
un rapport caché
concernant le lycée Stanislas,
l'établissement
en contrat avec l'Etat financé
sur fonds publics
ne respecte pas les élèves.
Il y règnerait
un climat homophobe
et une culture du viol
qui les mettent
en danger.
Les contenus
scolaires n'y
sont pas entièrement dispensés.
Le lycée Stanislas
est un territoire perdu
de la République où la loi
ne s'appliquerait pas.
On y pratiquerait le séparatisme.
Le directeur de cet
établissement affirme "obéir
à cette double légitimité
faisant prévaloir celle
de l'Eglise catholique
par rapport à celle
de la République."
Cet établissement
a mis en place
un système de contournement
de la vie commune.
Les élèves échappent
donc à Parcoursup.
Obéissant à la consigne
du gouvernement,
le préfet a prononcé la rupture
du contrat d'association
avec un lycée
qui s'opposait aux valeurs
de la République.
En toute logique,
sur la base des mêmes griefs,
le collège Stanislas
devrait aussi voir
son contrat d'association rompu.
Sinon, chacun
constaterait que certains
sont protégés.
Sommes-nous en République?
Allez-vous casser
le contrat d'association
avec le collège
séparatiste Stanislas?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Prisca Thevenot.
- Prisca Thevenot:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député,
suite à l'envoi du rapport
concernant l'établissement
Stanislas,
le 2 août 2023,
plusieurs recommandations
ont été émises et,
immédiatement,
des actions ont été
mises en place
par Gabriel Attal,
qui était alors ministre
de l'Education nationale
et de la Jeunesse.
Le rapport a été transmis
aux autorités compétentes.
Des échanges ont eu lieu
entre le rectorat
et le directeur
diocésain en janvier
et en septembre derniers.
Sur le parent d'élève
qui aurait assuré
des séances de catéchèse
à titre bénévole
et qui aurait tenu des propos
à caractère homophobes,
Gabriel Attal a déclenché
immédiatement l'article 40.
Pour Parcoursup,
les recommandations
ont été suivies d'effets,
puisque des investigations
ont été menées
et des rappels
ont été adressés
aux personnes concernées.
Vous parlez de valeurs
républicaines
et de sa capacité
à faire république.
Votre sujet,
ce n'est pas Stanislas.
C'est que vous
n'aimez pas,
dans sa globalité, l'école privée.
Vous n'aimez pas
les Français
qui ont choisi
de mettre leurs enfants
dans l'école privée.
Vous êtes en train de faire
une différence
entre tous les enfants.
Ensemble, ici,
nous devrions être unis
pour travailler
à l'excellence,
pour nos enfants
et notre République.
Vous nous donnez des grandes
leçons républicaines,
apprenez à les appliquer!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, madame
la ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
Philippe Juvin.
- Philippe Juvin: Madame
la présidente,
ma question s'adresse
à la ministre de la Santé.
Nous avions alerté
votre prédécesseur
en juillet dernier.
20.000 étrangers
concouraient pour exercer
la médecine en France.
Vous aviez décidé
d'en conserver seulement 2700.
Nous n'avons jamais
compris pourquoi.
Nous avons besoin de médecins.
C'est assez absurde
de tronquer le nombre.
Vous avez ensuite
indiquer prendre
tous ceux qui avaient le niveau.
Le concours a bel et bien eu lieu.
La catastrophe annoncée
n'a pas tardé.
Hier,
dans la précipitation,
vous avez pris
des mesures de rustine.
Allez-vous enfin admettre
tous les médecins
qui ont le niveau?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Catherine Vautrin.
- Catherine Vautrin: Merci.
Monsieur le député,
vous l'avez dit,
il y a le sujet
de ces praticiens
qui travaillent
dans notre système de soins
et dont la présence
est tout à fait importante.
C'est la raison
pour laquelle, conformément
à ce qu'a dit
le président
de la République,
le 16 janvier dernier,
il était important
de répondre aux attentes
de celles
et ceux qui travaillent
dans nos hôpitaux.
C'est le sens du décret
qui est sorti hier
et qui répond à cette évaluation
des compétences de 2023
et qui a permis
de clarifier la situation
de 2700 praticiens.
La situation
est la suivante:
lorsqu'ils ont validé l'examen
et qu'ils sont en poste
dans notre pays,
ils peuvent rester là où ils sont.
Nombreux sont les députés
qui m'ont alertée
sur la nécessité
qu'il y avait de trouver
des réponses
pour celles
et ceux qui attendaient
des réponses en matière de santé.
Le deuxième sujet
est celui des personnes
qui sont en dehors
de notre pays,
mais qui ont validé le diplôme.
D'ici la fin du trimestre,
ils seront en capacité
de venir exercer
dans notre pays.
Le troisième sujet,
c'est celui
de celles et ceux qui ont raté
cet examen
et pour lesquels
il y a une capacité
à retravailler d'ici 2024.
Il reste donc deux sujets:
la situation
de celles et ceux qui sont là
jusqu'en 2024 et aussi celui
de la validation.
Je ne doute pas
que nos concitoyens
qui attendent
des médecins de proximité
ont déjà une part de réponse.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le député?
- Philippe Juvin:
Vous n'avez pas répondu
à ma question
sur la transformation
du concours en examen.
Pour répondre
aux besoins de médecins,
il faut doubler
le numerus clausus,
il faut garantir
le SMIC aux experts
et appliquer
toutes les mesures
que nous avons votées
dans la proposition
de loi de mon excellent collègue.
Nos propositions,
soit vous les ignorez,
soit vous les confisquez
sans dire
que ça vient de chez nous.
C'est la stratégie du coucou.
Vous n'écoutez jamais
les propositions
des oppositions.
Acceptez cette idée extravagante
que d'autres
que vous puissent
avoir des idées intelligentes.
Nous comptons sur vous.
Ne soyez pas la ministre
d'un seul camp.
Soyez la ministre
qui écoute
tout le Parlement
et pas seulement
vos amis.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame la ministre?
- Catherine Vautrin:
Vous le savez,
le drame de notre pays,
c'est le manque
de médecins.
Vous connaissez
l'origine comme moi,
c'est le numerus clausus.
Le gouvernement
qui a eu le courage
de venir vers le numerus
apertus,
c'est celui-là!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Lysiane Métayer.
- Lysiane Métayer:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Depuis hier,
les bateaux de pêche
de la façade atlantique
sont à quai en application
de la décision
du Conseil d'Etat
d'interdire la pêche
dans le golfe
de Gascogne
pendant un mois.
Cette décision fait
suite à une saisine
de quatre associations
environnementales visant
à réduire les captures
accidentelles
de petits cétacés.
C'est un véritable
coup de massue porté
à nos pêcheurs
qui avaient engagé
de lourds investissements,
conformément
au plan d'action
entre le gouvernement
et les professionnels
en faveur d'une pêche
plus responsable.
J'étais à leurs côtés
dès le 26 décembre.
Plusieurs autres
de mes collègues
sont mobilisés.
La décision du Conseil
d'Etat vient anéantir
tous les efforts
entrepris
alors que la filière
souffre
depuis de nombreuses années.
Brexit, hausse du gasoil,
conséquences
de la guerre en Ukraine...
S'ils ont toujours fait
face et continuent
de le faire, cette décision
remet en cause
leur savoir-faire
en opposant écologie et économie.
Alors même
que nous leur devons
notre souveraineté
alimentaire,
avec cette décision,
ce sont plus de 450 navires
de pêche qui sont impactés
dans le golfe
de Gascogne,
mais c'est aussi l'ensemble
de la filière de pêche
de la façade atlantique
qui est menacée.
Dans ma circonscription,
ce sont 3000 emplois
qui sont concernés.
Comment rassurer nos pêcheurs?
Comment les accompagner
dans cette nouvelle crise?
De tout temps,
ils ont fait preuve
d'un savoir-faire indispensable.
Nous leur devons notre soutien.
L'année 2024 est celle de la mer.
Ne devons-nous pas
alors réarmer
notre filière pêche
et faire de la France
une nation maritime?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
le Premier ministre.
- Gabriel Attal:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Madame la députée, quand
on parle de souveraineté
alimentaire
de la France
et de richesse
pour notre pays,
évidemment que la pêche
a une place absolument majeure
dans notre souveraineté
et nous pouvons
en être fiers à l'international.
Nous avons une filière
pêche puissante,
d'une grande qualité
et passionnée
par son métier.
A l'occasion des Assises
de l'économie
de la mer en décembre
dernier, le ministre
de
l'Agriculture s'est engagé sur 750
millions d'euros
dans les années
à venir pour renforcer
les flottes, pour améliorer
l'attractivité
de ces métiers
ainsi que notre compétitivité.
Ce gouvernement
et cette majorité
ont été aux côtés
de nos pêcheurs
dans toutes les tempêtes
des dernières années:
au moment du Brexit,
au moment du Covid,
au moment des crises
liées à l'inflation
des prix de l'énergie
après la guerre
en Ukraine.
C'est 350 millions d'euros
qui ont été engagés.
Vous me permettrez
de rendre hommage
au travail d'Hervé Berville.
Vous l'avez dit,
après la décision
du Conseil d'Etat,
c'est une nouvelle tempête
que nos pêcheurs affrontent.
Nous avons déjà annoncé
un certain nombre
de mesures pour les soutenir.
La décision du Conseil d'Etat
ne s'appliquait qu'aux navires
français,
mais nous l'avons étendue
aux navires étrangers.
Nous allons la faire respecter.
Les navires
étrangers
ne pourront pas pêcher là
où les navires français
ne peuvent pas pêcher.
Nous avons décidé aussi
d'indemnisations importantes.
Nous prévoyons
une indemnisation
de 80 à 85%
du chiffre d'affaires
pour les pêcheurs,
un soutien à la filière.
Il y a aussi
la possibilité de recourir
au chômage partiel.
Nous allons
mobiliser rapidement
le secteur bancaire.
Nos pêcheurs
comme nos agriculteurs font
partie de tous
ces Français
qui n'ont pas envie
de survivre
avec des aides.
Ils veulent vivre de leur travail.
Nous sommes au
rendez-vous
pour les accompagner
financièrement,
mais ils ne se lèvent pas
pour aller chercher
des aides.
Ils se lèvent pour leur passion.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Nicolas Meizonnet.
- Nicolas Meizonnet:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Agriculture.
A ce jour, nous n'avons
ni ministre,
ni secrétaire d'Etat
chargés de la Mer.
450 navires
dans les eaux du golfe
de Gascogne
resteront à quai
pendant un mois,
interdits d'exercer
leur activité.
Une victoire
pour des associations "écolos",
mais surtout anti-pêche,
qui qualifient
les chalutiers
"d'abattoirs flottants".
Vous soutenez
des politiques punitives
de l'Union Européenne.
C'est toute une filière
qui est en train
d'être assassinée.
Au Grau-du-Roi,
dans ma circonscription,
le nombre de chalutiers
a chuté de 35
à 15 en moins de 20 ans.
La flotte française
a perdu la moitié
de ses navires.
Pourtant, en France,
nous sommes dotés
de trois façades maritimes
exceptionnelles.
Nous importons
désormais deux tiers
des produits de la mer
que nous consommons.
Quelle hypocrisie!
Essentiels à notre souveraineté
alimentaire,
exerçant dans des conditions
parfois difficiles,
les pêcheurs se voient dicter
une politique commune
à Bruxelles totalement
déconnectée
des réalités en France.
Régulation du nombre
de jours de sortie
en mer, explosion
des coûts
du gasoil,
ils sont de plus
en plus nombreux
à vouloir "quitter le navire".
La colère monte
et elle est légitime.
Allez-vous laisser
notre filière
de pêche française disparaître?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
le Premier ministre.
- Gabriel Attal:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Monsieur le député,
vous pouvez utiliser
tous les mots
que vous voulez,
charger l'Union
Européenne
de tous les mots
que vous voulez,
mais la réalité,
c'est que l'événement
qui a le plus mis
en danger nos pêcheurs
ces dernières années,
c'est le Brexit.
Les premiers soutiens
du Brexit, c'était vous,
le RN!
Il y a même,
dans les quelques communes
que vous dirigez
et que les élus
du Rassemblement
National dirigent,
des rues du Brexit
qui ont été inaugurées.
C'est dire à quel point
vous le soutenez.
C'était la plus grande
mise en danger
de nos pêcheurs.
Nous sommes parvenus
à sauver nos prêcheurs
grâce à tout le travail
qui a été engagé
par le gouvernement
et par Michel Barnier.
Vous parlez des risques
pour nos pêcheurs,
mais à aucun moment,
lorsqu'ils
ont fait l'objet
de grandes difficultés,
notamment sur les prix
du carburant,
ni au Parlement
européen, ni ici,
on a entendu les députés
du Rassemblement National
les défendre.
Nous avons prolongé
un dispositif
de soutien aux pêcheurs
pour leur carburant
à cinq reprises.
Nous ne vous avons pas entendu
les défendre.
Ils font face aujourd'hui
à une grande angoisse
et à une grande
inquiétude liée
à cette décision
qui les empêche
de sortir dans le golfe
de Gascogne
pour 450 navires
du fait de la capture
de cétacés.
On est au rendez-vous
pour les accompagner,
comme on l'a fait
dans toutes les tempêtes.
Je suis parfaitement
conscient
que ce
qu'ils attendent,
ce n'est pas des aides,
c'est de pouvoir travailler.
Le coeur
de notre mobilisation,
c'est de leur permettre
de reprendre
la mer aussi vite que possible.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Philippe Fait.
- Philippe Fait:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Plus de deux mois
et demi
après les premières inondations
dans le Pas-de-Calais,
de nombreux concitoyens
sont encore les pieds dans l'eau.
De nombreux
résidents ont perdu
leur maison et les solutions
de relogement
ne sont pas toujours adaptées.
De nombreuses
entreprises peinent
à retrouver leur activité
ou sont définitivement perdues.
De nombreux artisans
sont dans l'attente d'une prise
en charge par leurs assurances.
L'hiver sera encore long,
sans véritable solution
pour assurer
la reprise du travail.
Au quotidien,
je partage leur désarroi.
Un quotidien aussi marqué
par de nombreuses visites
ministérielles.
Je veux remercier
les différents membres
du gouvernement
qui ont pris la mesure
de la situation,
comme vous, monsieur
le Premier ministre,
le premier jour
de votre nomination.
Des solutions d'urgence
sont en place,
mais nous sommes encore loin
du bout
du tunnel.
La détresse a fait
place à la colère.
Aujourd'hui,
nous devons faire face
en gardant foi
en la résilience
et en la ténacité des habitants
du Pas-de-Calais.
Ils me le disaient
encore ce dimanche
lors d'une réunion
à Montreuil-sur-Mer,
ils souhaitent
s'engager et donner
leur avis pour l'avenir
de leur territoire.
Ils veulent
être pleinement acteurs
pour que cela ne se reproduise
plus.
Les élus locaux veulent
également pouvoir agir,
mais avec les mains
libres, forts
de leur expérience
et de leur connaissance
du territoire.
Tout ça ne pourra se faire
qu'à hauteur d'homme
en regroupant tous
les organismes concernés.
Les habitants connaissent
leur territoire.
Les élus locaux connaissent
Faisons-leur confiance.
Libérons les énergies
et simplifions
les démarches administratives
qui entravent
trop notre action collective.
C'est un appel
de détresse que je lance.
Pouvez-vous nous rappeler
les actions engagées
par le gouvernement?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Prisca Thevenot.
- Prisca Thevenot:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député,
je vous remercie
de votre question
qui rappelle l'importance
de continuer
à nous mobiliser
et de ne pas oublier
les habitants
qui ont été durement touchés.
Ils font preuve
d'une résilience
et d'une ténacité remarquables.
Je sais qu'une
fois retourné
sur vos terres,
vous pourrez leur faire part
de ces paroles.
Le ministre de la Transition
écologique,
qui me demande
de le représenter aujourd'hui,
est en ce moment
à leurs côtés
pour tenir le premier
comité ministériel
de suivi de la situation
des sinistrés.
Cette réunion sera
l'occasion de faire
le suivi et de répondre
aux attentes fortes
et légitimes des habitants
et des élus locaux concernant
la simplification
des procédures
et le financement
de la lutte
contre les inondations.
Le président
de la République a assuré
son soutien aux habitants
durement touchés
et un fonds de 50 millions d'euros
a été débloqué.
Le Premier ministre
en a dessiné
les contours
lors de son premier déplacement
en tant que Premier ministre,
le 9 janvier dernier.
Ce fonds s'ajoute
aux financements déjà apportés
par l'Etat.
Le gouvernement étudie
des mécanismes supplémentaires
pour répondre
plus précisément aux besoins
des artisans et des commerçants.
281 communes ont déjà fait l'objet
d'une reconnaissance
de l'Etat en situation
de catastrophe naturelle.
Un deuxième décret
viendra compléter
ce premier décret.
Le gouvernement
est pleinement mobilisé
ainsi que le Premier
ministre lui-même,
qui s'assure que les actions
engagées soient
bien mises en place.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
René Pilato.
- René Pilato: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre
de l'Economie.
Vous promettiez
une augmentation
du prix de l'électricité
inférieure
à 10%, parole tenue,
vous assénez 9,8%.
"Chers pauvres,
vous avez sauté
des repas en 2023.
Grâce à la bienveillance
de Bercy,
vous allez en sauter 10% de plus!"
Les pauvres vous remercient.
Souvent, les plus démunis
doivent choisir
entre payer la facture
d'électricité
ou payer la cantine.
Les prix n'ont jamais
été aussi hauts
et ce n'est pas fini.
Les prix sont totalement
déconnectés
des prix de connexion,
mais ils permettent
de gaver les énergéticiens
comme jamais.
Vos services
sont-ils au courant
que l'explosion des prix
de l'énergie laminent
les forces vives du pays?
Quelque chose
en France
ne tourne pas rond.
La sortie des tarifs
réglementés,
c'est vous.
Les boulangeries
qui ferment,
c'est vous.
Les TPE et PME
qui ferment, c'est vous.
L'explosion
de la pauvreté,
dans ce pays,
ça se sait, c'est vous.
Jusqu'où allez-vous
affamer et tondre
la population
pour que les Bernard Arnault,
Bettencourt et les 43
milliardaires
qui ont doublé leur fortune en 10
ans soient protégés?
Renoncer à cette hausse
du 10% serait
une décision au service du peuple.
Allez-vous renoncer
à votre hausse d'impôts
et trouver l'argent ailleurs?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Ce qui ne tourne pas rond
en France,
c'est décidément la NUPES.
Quelle incohérence
dans vos propos!
Vous nous dites
qu'il faut protéger
le pouvoir d'achat
de nos compatriotes
contre la flambée des prix
de l'électricité,
je ne peux pas
être plus d'accord,
mais pour cela,
il y avait un instrument
formidable qui s'appelle
le bouclier tarifaire
sur l'électricité.
Aucun autre pays
européen ne l'a mis
en place.
Nous avons protégé
tous les Français
contre l'explosion des prix
de l'électricité
et vous avez voté contre.
Pour protéger
le pouvoir d'achat,
il fallait protéger
les minima sociaux
et les indexer
sur l'inflation,
vous avez voté contre.
Il fallait revaloriser
les retraites minimales.
Nous l'avons fait,
vous avez voté contre.
Pour protéger
le pouvoir d'achat
de ceux qui travaillent,
il fallait indexer
le barème des revenus
sur l'inflation,
vous avez voté contre.
Vous avez voté
contre tout ce qui protégeait
le pouvoir d'achat des Français.
Vous avez proposé
de défiscaliser
les heures supplémentaires.
Dans le fond,
votre conception
de la France,
elle est très simple:
toujours plus de taxes,
toujours
plus d'impôts,
de redistribution,
mais moins de rémunération
du travail
et de récompenses
pour ceux qui travaillent.
Nous avons exactement
la vision inverse.
Nous récompensons
ceux qui ont un emploi
et qui font vivre la nation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
Monsieur le député?
- René Pilato:
Votre politique économique
est tellement bonne
qu'il y a un tiers
des Français qui sautent un repas.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La séance des questions
au gouvernement
est terminée.